foreign
she is currently in a romantic
relationship with a
50-something-year-old man she's just
turned 18 in March she is a child under
the spell of an adult that's why they
need adults in their lives to protect
them from predators like this man
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show
show
made up of real people going through
real challenges and I'm gonna walk
alongside you and we're going to figure
out what comes next I got two decades of
sitting with people
when the wheels have fallen off in their
marriages in their personal life in the
worst of the worst moments when sitting
with people who have lost loved ones who
are considering taking their life all
it's been worse in my life
and that's what we do here on the show
my promise is I'm not going to have all
the answers all the time sometimes I
have to call some friends and reach out
to a to an expert or two across the
country my promises I'm gonna tell you
the truth and I'll sit down in the mud
with you we will figure out what to do
next if you want to be on the show we're
going to talk about marriage we can talk
about mental health whatever's going on
in this in this wild mental health
ecosystem we got going on in this
country
um sometimes talk about exercise
nutrition sometimes we talk about
schools what's going on the lives of
your kids we talk about all whatever's
going on in your life I'm here to walk
alongside you if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 leave a message and Jenna
or um Kelly will call you back and we'd
love to have you on the show or go to
John deloney.com ask a-s-k
so let's start the day show off here
down the street in Nashville Tennessee
and let's chat it up with Ray it's a
shame about Ray what's up Ray hey John I
can't put them on your show right now
dude I can't believe you're talking to
me this is awesome
I just appreciate it I mean you've saved
my my wife and I thousands of dollars in
therapy so just by your show alone so I
appreciate
um actually getting to be beyond your
your show so I appreciate you having the
courage to give me a buzz dude so what's
up man I I mean it I don't really know
where to start
um so I'm hoping you can kind of lead me
with as I pose the question kind of lead
the conversation so I feel like there's
a lot behind it okay
um but
I just find it difficult to let myself
cry
even when I'm like my body is telling me
I need to
I just like you know even in a quiet
place it just doesn't happen and it's
not like you know when I'm watching a
good movie like or grateful for my
family and all like I can the tears come
a little bit of that but it's like when
I'm dealing with
um like loss or stress or like shame or
disappointment in myself or just sadness
and it just doesn't come so I'm hoping
you can guide me to know what to do
give me an example of a Time
when you were thinking in real time I
should be crying right now and I want to
cry but I can't
give me a specific example
so when I this happened actually just a
couple days ago
um and it's it's like little experiences
like this that kind of add up
um that lead me to like feel that build
and it just doesn't come so like my son
he loves the projector we have we call
it projector night where he you know we
we put it up on the wall and and all
that he wanted to put it up a new place
he's three years old by the way
um so he we put up a show and people
wanted to put a new spot spot wasn't big
enough to fit the screen you know but
he's pushing all the buttons and I'm
trying to take it down and up and I lose
a little bit of my my cool not like
hardcore not yelling at him or anything
like that but just like
like but we gotta you know almost like I
was blaming him it's like dude he's
three but it shouldn't push my buttons
like that but then I then I go into the
shame cycle
where I start beating myself up
and I'm
feel this like heaviness and I apologize
to him you know sound like I feel sad
that I reacted that way I chose to react
that way sorry but I'll be better next
time or
um but man it is that and then I do
something a little something else or
like I don't do as good at work and I
feel this like if I don't do a good job
on a project or whatever
it then builds up and I just start to
feel that
and I don't have like I don't take time
as much as I should maybe to to sit and
just be alone with it but even then it
doesn't always come
man you you are describing your life as
though you're watching a movie of
yourself critiquing it
and
brother I gotta tell you man that that
is the quintessential
that's the quintessential definition of
trauma is separation from your oneself
who told you man
that the way you do life is wrong
because when I hear a guy I hear a guy
that is
like so far ahead
of millions and millions of men dads
husbands trying to do
better than what they got
but there's this voice in the stands
that just won't let you get better
the inner critic it's like the judge so
yeah but that inner critic that's
somebody's voice whose voice is that
um I
probably my my parents
um
when I was you've been defending them
for way too long they're grown-ups they
can take care of themselves
yeah I have been you gotta stop
but you know yeah I mean for example
like when I was a kid you know when I
when I'd cry this is something that came
to my mind like my dad would be like
here comes the fire engine
crime more you know and then but why did
he make you cry more
because it was like it didn't matter to
him no no no no no no that's not it
you cried more
because when you were hurting you needed
one thing
and that was a dad who saw you and said
come here buddy
yeah and damn it he didn't give you that
and in fact he widened the Gulf
he made that Chasm between the two of
you wider and he looked at you and
blamed you here comes the fireworks here
comes the fire trucks
yeah and so it's it's kind of like being
in the water
and you realize it's it's too deep you
can't touch and you start panicking and
your dad makes eye contact with you and
swims away
that's why you cried harder
I came from your guts
see what I'm saying I I do and I bet
that happened in high school too
were you a kid that got good grades and
then the the first response is
wow would another of a have killed you
well I'm
funny I was homeschooled I was pulled
out really young and and had no
structure with this Cooling and it was
like here's a math book see ya I'm gonna
go teach piano lessons and I'm like okay
I'll try to learn how to do this so I
had no structure really no help in that
regard
um but were you judged as though you did
yeah it was like why you know you need
to be doing this and it's like critical
and not like
I know
it was yeah it was very much like here
it set me up didn't really set me up for
success
um but I mean there were some great
blessings that came from that here you
go stop defending them for sure for five
minutes oh dude I know five minutes no I
I am a perfect example of that I
yeah I also had to be there for my mom I
mean my parents are divorced I had to
carry a lot of her worries and or I
chose to or she put them on me no you
didn't know what to do kids don't choose
you didn't
that became your job and your role
so how do I
what do I do now like as much as it's
like okay I can I've been I have like
novel sized notes in my phone
of everything of how breaking it down
and you know trying to make sense of it
all but in the end it's like okay but I
can try and make sense of it but what do
I do now it's like
I can't really
it doesn't do me much good just simply
knowing what happened it's like well I'm
dealing with this now so what do I do
how do I how do I allow myself to feel
again feel that vulnerability like to be
truly vulnerable
in my own skin and be okay
regardless of I don't want like
validation from others to cry I don't
want to have to put on Sarah Mclaughlin
to cry or I want to be able to just like
allow myself to cry
okay first I want you to unhook yourself
from crying being this magic Finish Line
okay
so
similar to like somebody who's been
working in the real world for 10 years
and they have an MBA and they're telling
me they need to go back to get a PhD in
business so they can learn how to do
business better I want to tell you man
at this point you can just you you can
just get what you need off the internet
so you it's it's a false Finish Line
okay
okay I don't want that to be your marker
because what's going to happen is you're
gonna cry and you're still gonna be sad
you're gonna be frustrated you're still
gonna feel like the inside of your chest
is cemented shut and all of your guts
have been super glued together which is
like which is how you feel
and crying well
crying is the result of the work crying
isn't the destination Okay so
I'm running through my head here
I'll be as vague as I can
um
[Music]
last time I prefer specific if you need
if you're asking me no no no I'm trying
to decide how much I'm going to disclose
here
um I'll just it we're here so last week
um I've been seeing a counselor
I'm halfway through writing this last
book I was brought back to some memories
and stories in my life that I had
evidently
buried far far away and I knew him I
knew I didn't think about it very much
and it was uh like getting hit by a
truck
and I know him
I'm write them down like you I've got
pages and pages in my notes app on my
phone and in my little diary Journal
things
and then for the first time in 40 years
I spoke it out loud in front of a
counselor
and I felt
oh I can't describe it other than I'm
still processing it
but I felt like I dropped a hundred
pounds
and then I went home and I had a
conversation and I've been married to
the same woman for 20 years we've been
together for probably 25 26 now and I
never told her some of this stuff
and yet another 100 pounds so I tell you
this there is only one path to
vulnerability
and that is sitting in front of somebody
else who could burn you who could hurt
you
and you saying here's what happened
that's the path
yeah
and I don't know how it works I'm sure
there's an oxytocin release and I'm sure
partridge in a pear tree and dopamine
and serotonin and jumping jacks and cold
tubs I'm sure all that crap is a thing I
don't care
what I know beyond a shadow of a doubt
from the research but I know beyond a
shadow of a doubt for my own life what I
know beyond a shadow of a doubt from
last week
is that
the thing that melts the cement in your
chest
is sitting across somebody and saying
this happened to me
that's why every major religion
throughout all of human history has a
confession element to it and we've made
confession about bad things we did
that's not the origin of confession
confession the origin of confession is
here's what happened
and I think it's been woven through
every religion throughout human history
because it's a it's it's got a healing
element to it it's medicinal
for lack of better terms it's spiritual
it's a gift
are there things that you've experienced
that your wife doesn't even know
yeah not specifics you know some general
General uh
things haven't gotten into the dirt of
it all
have you ever sat down with a counselor
and just said hey this is what happened
no no well I mean some things but not
not the stuff like not this stuff that's
right
and what you're trying to do is I want
you to follow the pattern here you're
having a conversation with yourself
it's reinforced by your younger self
that then turns your body up and starts
spinning and then you've got to have a
conversation to bring yourself back down
and you're in a loop-de-loop and another
word for loop-de-loop is a hurricane or
a tornado
and that my friend is anxiety
and then you find yourself trying to
predict what she's gonna say what what's
going to happen over here if your boss
emails you at 4 pm in the afternoon you
can't breathe
yeah yeah and that needs to happen
bro I mean
uh
crying's good for me crying is cathartic
the other day I was um
I don't mind we're just gonna tell all
all Delaney's laundry we're just gonna
put all out there today
um I went to Texas for an event for a
couple of days working with a really
remarkable business and I got to sit
with a couple of buddies who have been
my rider dies for almost 30 years now
and their wives I consider them some of
my best friends it's we're a gang and we
all went out to dinner with just me and
my two buddies and their two wives just
us no kids and I secretly handed my
debit card to the waitress under the
table pay for the whole meal
and I've had a season of blessing in the
last year it's been silly we sold a lot
of books and a lot of questions for
humans cards
and my buddy John King looked at me
and he said you will never do that again
and I said hey man it's been a good
season I've had a good little run here
y'all picked me up for years these are
guys these two guys paid my rent
and he said you have to have a place
where you can pull up to a table
and we love you because you're you not
because you're buying us dinner never do
that again
and I was telling my wife this story
when I got back to Nashville
and I just started weeping in a
restaurant
it just came
because I was overwhelmed by how much
those four people love me
and they don't care how famous and they
don't care they don't care anything
because they were my friends they loved
me when they were paying my rent
one of those guys I had to call one time
and say hey I've got like a real bad
issue with my health and I may need to
go to the ER and I've Got No Room on a
credit card can I borrow your Southwest
card to go to the ER
and he said I'll drive you
that's how poor and you see what I'm
saying but I was so overwhelmed but the
goal wasn't to cry at that lunch
the guy was the goal was to say out loud
to somebody that I care and love my wife
I can't believe how blessed I am
and I can't believe I've got people that
I don't have to prove myself to
yeah I feel like I I don't I mean other
than my wife that's the best person to
be able to do this with
but I if you talk about having guy
friends I don't have guy friends I mean
it's been I need guy friends too so like
when you when you talk about that like
you'll be able to sit down with dinner
it's not about what you can offer them
you know it's just like
you yeah you are enough you know we tell
the same stories for 30 years yeah
here's the deal
how old are you now
I'm 33 33.
you've got
I I don't know you start today
and you'll be having this conversation
when you're 53 and you've been right or
dying with a group of guys for 20 years
it's easier when they shove you all in a
college dorm and say May the force be
with you right May the odds be forever
in your favor and you don't have that
luxury
but you got money now all right you've
got like a car
and it's just a matter of starting the
challenge for you is those kind of
relationships
burned you alive as a kid man
and my guess is you and I could talk for
a long time and
you're trying to navigate a mom who used
you like a water bottle usually as a
drug right you were oxygen for her in a
dad that was so critical of his own
freaking son man
that he mocked his pain laughed at him
because your cries were annoying and too
loud like a fire truck engine
my guess is you've probably made some
dumb mistakes along the way trying to
find connection with anybody anywhere or
any place anyhow and you ultimately
learned I'm just gonna
take my tools and go home
it's hard
tears will come
but I want you to focus your energy on
vulnerability
on finding a person
a couple of people that you can just be
honest with for the first time
for me that needed to be a professional
I need to sit down and say hey this
stuff happened
and
it was just like the glue melted man
and my my dearest hope for you my
brother my neighbor here in town is that
you'll have the courage to make those
calls
sit down with your wife and say hey I
have some dark stuff I'd love to tell
you about but it's also going to be
heavy so you tell me when you're ready
because she can feel that disconnection
between the two of you two
you're worth
connecting
I'm grateful for you my brother hang on
the line I'm gonna send you a copy of
own your past change your future for
free
um read that it'll give you a blueprint
out
I'm grateful for you man thanks for
trying to be the best husband and Dad
you can be
now I want you to take that level of
care and look in the mirror and love
that guy that much too
we'll be right back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hallow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we're back let's go out to
Boone North Carolina and talk to Gabriel
what's up Gabriel
yes hey how are you hi yes good great
grand wonderful how are you
doing pretty well excellent what's up
so
uh um it might get a little emotional
it's all good man
I would like to know how
the best way is to go about maintaining
a relationship with my sister
um when she is currently in a romantic
relationship with a 50-something year
old man who I believe possibly groomed
her
um she's just turned 18 in March oh geez
whoa
yeah
so
um
we this had been going on I personally
knew the man before she did
um and so she
had met him and would see him on a
weekly basis out at a like a social
setting a social function and um
just over time started having like this
little crush on him and then it started
developing into more
um and
there were measures put up to where they
wouldn't have any more contact in like
the social setting was done away with so
that way they wouldn't be seeing each
other anymore
um and she had told everybody in the
family that she wasn't seeing him
anymore
that there was no conversation anymore
that there was no
um seeing him at all but things got kind
of funny back in
let's say September and we thought that
there's possibility that she was
definitely seeing him and talking to him
so I actually had a very upfront
conversation with her about what this
would look like for her life what it
would look like
um like all the different possibilities
and I also was very clear about how it
would change our relationship
um
and then I called him
and I asked him directly you know are
you having any relations with her right
now are you talking to her currently she
has plans to come and move in with you
do you know anything about this
and he said no he knew nothing that
there was no contact they weren't
talking but some of the things that he
was saying led me to believe that they
definitely were talking
um
so yeah some time passed and went on
my mother and stepfather ended up
involving the police but the police said
that legal age was 16 so there was
nothing that they could do either
freaking North Carolina dude
so unbelievable
if you are a legislator in the state of
North Carolina you should be ashamed
with with yourself you shouldn't be able
to sleep
right it's just disgusting
50 years old
with a 16 year old
yeah
so um God Almighty what the what the
hell's happening to our country man
I don't know God it's so disgusting it's
just disgusting
my God I urged her to
um hey here's the thing you're not
there is no conversation you can have
with her
she is a child under the spell of an
adult that's why they need adults in
their lives to protect them from
predators like this man
there's not a conversation you haven't
had with her that where she would go oh
okay I get it now that's not gonna
happen
she is living in an altered reality
which is why
a consent age of 16.
so insane
golly man
so I'll tell you this I'm proud of you
for calling him Direct
I'm proud for your mother and stepfather
call the police
as you were talking I kept saying hey
there's gonna be phone records there's
going to be
all the photos she sent him that he
requested from her it's gonna be all
that crap is going to be out there and
discoverable because it's electronic but
I forgot you're in North Carolina so
disgusting
here's oh super helpless yeah I I wish I
had another I wish I had I wish I had
something else I could tell you
I feel helpless for you
so I'm gonna tell you something that
nobody else is going to tell you okay
and that is
it's the great Evander Holyfield
versus Mike Tyson move
okay
here's what the move was
everybody was terrified of Mike Tyson he
would beat people before they even got
in the ring
and he had an uppercut that came from
the floor and would knock your head to
the moon and he had a very particular
way he moved his right foot when he was
engaging in this uppercut
and what happened was everybody when
they felt his body shifting they would
back up a few inches
which gave them gave him the exact space
he needed to land that crushing blow
and then he fought Evander Holyfield who
talks about how he trained for months
that every time his body Mike Tyson's
body went to to make that maneuver he
stepped in got really close
which made that punch impossible to land
and over time he wore Mike Tyson out and
defeated the undefeatable
so here's what I want to tell you
every time you get an arms link from her
that's when you're gonna get hurt
and that's when she's gonna get hurt
so I'm gonna tell you to do something
crazy I want you to lean in and get real
close
would she go to a weekly breakfast with
you or a weekly lunch with just YouTube
just to talk about sister stuff
um
I mean it might be a possibility to do
it over the phone but we're currently
living about five hours apart okay
I'd set that up
I'd set up a weekly letter with her
so that she gets something in the mail
from you every week
and here's what we're doing
We are Never Gonna Let Her completely
detach from reality
one day she's going to open her eyes and
go oh god what have I done
and we want to give her a trail of bread
crumbs back to you
and that she will immediately turn
scared and look to her left and you will
have been standing there the whole time
and most advice what you're gonna get is
we'll just cut her off forget about her
she'll come crawl him back and I think
that that's that kind of wisdom has
given us the the world that we inhabit
now I think it's wrong
and so I would love for you to say hey
you're my sister I wanna we're gonna
talk every week and put a Time on the
calendar that you don't ever Miss
and you might get off the phone
Gabrielle and just cry
yeah
they keep showing up for her
and keep showing up for her
and there may be moments when you have
to put boundaries in like hey I want you
to come visit and you can say Hey you
know I really don't like I really
I don't want to be around him
I'd love to hang out with you I'd love
it love it love it but you know how I
feel about him so I'm asking you respect
my boundaries
and she's 18 so she'll probably say
something like if you don't love him
then you don't love me and you can say
you know that's dumb you know it's not
true
yeah right so there will be those
moments and you know those will come
can I ask you a hard question
yeah of course was there anything in
your y'all's ecosystem growing up that
like
it's just not super common
what was that what was the the
breadcrumb trail that led her to this
guy
um she really wanted out of a house
that my parents had divorced and she was
the only sister like the only girl left
at home
um
with three brothers
and um was there abuse
my mom and stepdad don't have the best
relationship there's constant fighting
constant the house is constantly loud
and doesn't feel very stable
and that's just what you've heard you
don't even know exactly right
right
I mean there were ample opportunities
like we my husband and I
made it very clear that she could come
and live with us she had
um another sister who offered the same
thing that she could come and move in
and
I think it's just she waited too long
and then this looked like a really good
option and it's super hard now to have
like to continue a relationship because
I've got a five-month-old daughter and
under no circumstances do I want him
around her
it's really hard to see like if he was
pedophile who groomed her or if he was
an older man and it was like
it sounds so crazy but like right time
right circumstances even though it's so
wrong does that even make sense yeah I
was I'm always going to put that
lay that burden
um in the hands of the 50 year old
yeah all right
yeah and so I'm I mean if you're dancing
on that line it's just you yeah
you got issues as is but the man's
disgusting and there's just not a way
around it and the police have said dude
there's nothing we can do
so I think any any effort you spend
trying to dig into that at this point
after the police have been involved and
they've wiped their hands clean I I
don't know there's a lot more to do
yeah maybe you could dig around and see
if you could find out they were
contacting each other when she was only
15 instead of 16 but
I mean
maybe but right now he's playing the
letter of the law
right
I think and they did that very well yeah
I I think the
um I think the energy best spent is
creating a new relationship with her
that is distant enough from this guy
that she never loses touch with the fact
that her family loves her
and there may have been so much chaos
growing up that she just can't see the
forest from the trees she can't feel it
or see it
okay
but you can break through that and and
invite her back into your life not him
her right and this doesn't mean you give
her money
and this doesn't mean you fill in the
blank pay a rant this doesn't mean all
that kind of stuff
right that means we're talking every
week and if she wants to come down and
see her niece oh that'd be awesome
yeah
he can't come he's not welcome
so maybe the conversation with you and
your husband is setting up boundaries
for
um what is this relationship going to
look like with her
and again don't chase it to where you
get so close you fall over the edge too
but I want you to think of ways you can
lean in and get closer to your sister
not in a manipulative way but just in a
way that when she turns her head and
opens her eyes and goes oh no
everything that I'm involved in right
now is wrong
and I thought this was the only ticket
out of a house of chaos and abuse and I
was wrong
and you're right there you have been the
whole way
and for everybody listening out there if
you've got somebody in your life who you
love and you care about and making dumb
decisions
find ways you can re-engage the
relationship not not in
not
um don't give a drunk a drink or all
that kind of you know all that stuff
find a way you can reconnect
healing changing Behavior changing life
always comes the reconnection
always
we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself to help you set boundaries and
still have energy left to help others
without leaving yourself behind so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's totally online to
fit into your schedule you just fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so find more balance
find Wellness with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back and it's time for
another round of facts or your friends
let's do it
all right today we are talking about
the mental health benefits of exercise
and this will probably be the shortest
facts of your friends that we've ever
done
the mental health benefits of exercise
so I just went to um pull up the
one of the the top academic journals on
the planet nature
here's just a couple of Snippets
we conclude that exercise may be a way
to reduce depression and pain and
improve the quality of life in adult
subjects with fibromyalgia and should be
a part of the treatment for this
pathology that's kudo
who's the lead author on that paper
another paper a small a paper by the way
is another is just an inside way of
saying uh Journal article academic
Journal article a research study that
was done and that was written and
published at top tier Journal which is
called a paper
small study it was not a big study but
it was an important study
the paper is by Patton who is the lead
author
highlights the potential of hit which is
intense exercises
for improving Mental Health
in overweight women
with polycystic ovar ovary syndrome
it may be a viable strategy to reduce
symptoms of depression and anxiety in
women with PCOS polycystic ovary
syndrome
another paper by mock m-ok
he was the lead author and there's a
bunch of other authors on there combined
resistance and endurance inter inter
interventions elicited significant
long-lasting improvements in global
fatigue and were beneficial to the
remaining side effects individually
resistance and endurance interventions
not significantly improve these side
effects
resistance interventions elicited higher
benefits overall
exercise interventions have lasting
clinical benefits in ameliorating at
adjuvant therapy side effects which
negatively impact fitness and mental
wear well-being
and I believe this was in
within with breast cancer I may got that
wrong I think this was a this was
dealing with women who were dealing with
um cancer treatments suggesting that
weight training and cardiovascular
exercise cardio
doing those things together
helped the entire process
studies show
um this is from Lawrence Robertson
Robinson studies show that exercise can
treat mild to moderate depression as
effectively as antidepressant medication
but without the side effects
similar studies in the bajillions
discuss that about anxiety
I have personally
experienced a significant reduction in
OCD symptoms with
intense exercise
on the regular
I've also felt a reduction in ticks I
have several ticks where I blink or I'll
move my head or I'll count
a significant reduction in those as well
sleep is improved
exercise improves cellular function
it helps reset your nervous system
helps with chronic inflammation over the
long period of time after an extreme
bout of exercise or Hard Exercise
inflammation does rise in your body and
it actually has shown that it's gonna it
serves a purpose
but over time
it also helps with psychosomatic issues
when you feel chronic pain but doctors
are telling you we don't see any reason
why you should be hurting maybe there's
a psycho it's psychological in origin
lowers all cause mortality as the great
Dr Peter attia says
helps give us stronger bones muscles
you have to exercise if you want to be
well
ta-da
if you want to really nerd out about
this stuff
you can check out Dr huberman's podcast
especially he's got a multi
um series podcast with Dr Andy Galpin
who's just a savant you can check out Dr
Tia's work you can check out our friend
Elaine Norton's work Dr Lane Norton you
can check out the Mind pump guys
I cannot
emphasize this enough
mental health the way we have described
mental health and I say we I'm a member
of the mental health practitioner
Community we have described mental
health as simply the act of getting all
of your thoughts in the right order just
thinking the right thoughts and that's a
lie it is false
I had one professor and I haven't very
verified this with data just with a
professor a grad one of my doctoral
professors
told me that
Sigmund Freud the father of modern
psychotherapy
had really bad teeth issues and you know
he's got a well-documented cocaine issue
and he used cocaine to numb his gums
because he had bad teeth he was
self-conscious of his teeth and he was
so self-conscious that he had his
clients lay down and face the other way
so the whole Foundation of counter
transference and don't let your patient
look at you and just let them free
associate may have originated if my
professor was telling me the truth
from a man's being self-conscious about
the way his face looked
why do I tell you that
that is the basis of Mental Health
it's just talking and talking and
talking and talking and thinking and
fixing your thinking and talking and
talking and we've completely divorced
the body from the mind
so I'll say this as clear as possible
your brain can't function the way it was
designed to function if it is sitting
atop a body that is falling apart
the stress chemicals that cycle through
your body were designed for fight or
flight responses not click and type and
more murder podcast
that was a low blood Kelly
that wasn't very nice sorry
here's the deal
go for a walk
every day
Dr Emily nagotsky talks about folks who
just would look at her and say I I'm not
going to exercise I'm not going to move
I don't feel comfortable I don't know
what I'm doing I don't know any of these
exercises everyone's like you should
dead lift and squat I don't even know
what that is Squad is something I do in
the woods when I go to the bathroom and
there's no right I don't know what this
stuff is
So she recommends laying your bed
and start with your feet
and squeeze your feet as hard as you can
Flex them
and then relax and then move up your
body from your calves
to your hamstrings to your glutes to
your
quads all the way up neck your face and
then do that several times is that going
to be enough over the long term no not
at all it's a place to start
you can't be well unless you have a
practice of movement and exercise in
your daily life
um I haven't read the original paper so
I haven't talked about it here but
um
I did see a headline recently that of
all we've been talking about
microplastics and all this stuff and
pollute all this drama about the
lowering testosterone rates globally
and there's some indication it may
simply be we have moved from a
movement-based society to a sedentary
based society our bodies have said oh we
don't need this anymore
and it's going to stop making it because
that's how good our bodies are we don't
don't use it we lose it
all of the data I've seen over the last
couple of years suggests that weight
training is the single most important
thing you can do
followed by what they call zone two
which is
long steady state exercise where you can
still carry on a conversation so we're
walking
maybe a little bit of a Brisk Pace but
we're just walking we can still have a
conversation talk Chit Chat all time
we can run exercise bike and just watch
a show
write an exercise bike and read a book
I'd do that when I'm doing zone two or
listen to a podcast
and then once or twice a week every two
weeks just have a blowout session just
go really hard for a few minutes
and if you want to go down rabbit holes
on this
please go go see my my buddies at mind
pump please go follow Dr Lane Norton or
Dr Tia
There's real you can you can go to the
ends of the Earth with this stuff
but if all of us would make movement a
daily part of our lives but we would see
in short order as a less anxious Society
a less depressed Society
a society could think a little bit
clearer that could show up for each
other a little bit better
I have a habit of overdoing it and I
remember uh this is back in 2013
I was pushing it so hard that I just
swore I'm not going to lift for 60 days
and I just started walking around my
neighborhood in the morning for an hour
I lost 30 pounds
obviously I altered my diet what not two
but just simply the stress
so sometimes crushing and killing us no
it's not the right season
sometimes let's sign up for a marathon
let's just go do that
obviously obviously obviously meet with
your doctor
but please
for your kids
for your spouse
for your country
for your spiritual life for you
make movement make exercise a regular
part of your life
lift weights three to five days a week
go for a walk if you don't know how to
lift weights that's right
there's enough resources on the Internet
or go see a trainer for a couple times
and they'll walk you through some basic
things
Now's the Time
make movement a part of your everyday
life
and that's the platform
where we can build
a mentally healthy life we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back Kelly was talking
trash during the break yes let's make it
public bring it out all right so I felt
a little scene with the whole True Crime
thing the murder podcast
it was in the news today
that here we go a woman working at a
Plato's Closet which is a resale shop
um I can't remember what state but was
had been watching an Unsolved Mysteries
and recognize a little girl that had
been taken seven years ago and she is
now back home so ha
sometimes True Crime is beneficial
oh in North Carolina that we've been
dogging on today by the way so let's
just say that
there you have it America
there you have it
for every thousand people who smoke and
999 of them get cancer and die
one of them
saves a baby from drowning he should all
smoke
[Laughter]
good job Kelly
I'm just saying
sometimes it works out I had this
thought too this is this is kind of
getting a little meta here this is
picking up off that last uh
teaching segment we did about murder
podcast from the previous episode of the
show
I'm not a huge consumer of this stuff
but when I was working at the law school
um ah gosh I just lost it it's this
great it's a great program where they
oh my gosh are you kidding me Delaney
they they it's law students all across
the country work to
um go through old death penalty cases
what is it called
you're talking about the Innocence
Project good grief yeah what an
embarrassment I'm an idiot so I'm not an
idiot I said I wouldn't talk about it
about myself sorry the Innocence Project
so when I was working there I always
offered like hey I want to take a case
home
and they never gave me one because I
don't know what I'm doing but I had this
fantasy of solving it
how much of murder podcast especially
the unsold ones like cereal is there a
little bit of like I bet I could figure
it out
um I'd say that's fair I mean kind of
like like when your husband's like I've
been looking in this drawer it's not
there
you know you're like because you know it
is there
yeah and it's like the detective was
probably a man who missed the most
obvious thing that was right in front of
his face there you go right so way to
gender this too wait a gender is too
podcasts about murder are also a part of
the patriarchy and Kelly's gonna bring
it all down all right so as we wrap up
today's show
ah jeez
I would say Kelly this is your least
attractive tattoo and I'm not trying to
be weird but you have a giant kind of
offset
tiger above her knee it's it's just the
whole thing
which turns out she's a huge fan of
Survivor the band not the show with Jeff
Probst but the band
and every once in a while
if you listen really closely really
quietly out on your front porch at night
you'll hear Kelly singing from the top
of her lungs while looking at her tattoo
and her leg
the following
rising up
back on the street did my time took my
chances went the distance now I'm back
on my feet just a man in his will to
survive again there's the patriarchy so
many times it happens too fast
trade your passion for Glory don't lose
your grip on your dreams of the past you
must fight just to keep them alive
it's the eye of the tiger it's the
thrill of the fight rising up to the
challenge of our rival
the last known Survivor stalks his prey
in the night that's a little bit creepy
and he's watching us all ah again creepy
with the eye of the tiger
uh she's dancing I can see her other
corner of my eye and it's giving me the
heebie-gb
love y'all stay in school don't do drugs
bugs
[Music]